MALE SPEAKER: Thank you guys for
joining us here at the YouTube
space at the second
day of I/O. We're
so excited to have you
and talk about distribute.
And basically when we
talk about distribute
what we want to talk about is
once you design and develop
amazing product, how do
you get it out there?
I couldn't be more exciting than
to be joined by Aaron Grant who
is a co-founder of Thalmic
Labs to talk about how you
distribute an amazing
new technology which
is on the forefront
of wearables.
And after graduating
Y-Combinator and coming
in all the way from
Waterloo, we're
so excited to have
you here today, Aaron.
How are you doing?
AARON GRANT: I'm doing great.
It's a pleasure to be here.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Awesome.
So again, my inner Star
Wars fan could come out,
because I feel like
what you're developing
with your technologies
like the Force.
You're able to control things.
Not with your mind, but with
the power of wearable technology
and controlling what's in front
of you around all devices.
Can you give a little more
detail about what exactly
the Myo armband is
and how it came to be?
AARON GRANT: Yes.
So the Myo armband is what we
call a gesture control armband.
And it's a slim band that
you wear around your forearm,
like you'd wear a sweatband.
And it has a couple different
types of sensors in it
that actually detect the
motions and gestures you
make with your
hands and fingers.
And we allow you to use that to
control any of your technology,
whether it's your laptop or
your Smart TV or your tablet.
The possibilities are
pretty much endless.
The way it works is that
there's a couple different types
of sensors embedded
in the armband.
One of those is a
motion sensor that
tracks the position
and orientation
and movement of your arm.
And we combine that with the
proprietary muscle activity
sensors we've developed,
which actually detect
the electrical
signals that occur
when you contract your muscles.
So if I'm wearing a Myo
armband, and I make a fist,
just by reading the electrical
impulses from my muscles,
it can tell that my
hand is making a fast
or touching different
fingers together.
So that's what
the technology is.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Aaron, tell me about what
your favorite use case is?
You guys put together
a lot of materials,
a lot of videos about
you showing Myo in action
in the kitchen, a
military soldier using
it to control robots.
What's your favorite, most
mind blowing application
of your technology?
AARON GRANT: There's just so
many different possibilities,
it's tough to pick
one as a favorite.
One of the really
interesting ones to us
is being able to use this
to control other wearable
technology.
So as we see computing shifting
from being purely something
that you do sitting in
a chair at your desk
to interacting with all
these different devices
with different form factors.
And some have screens
and some don't.
And all this different
stuff out there now.
Using the Myo to be able
to naturally interact
with those devices in
a way that makes sense
is something that myself
and everyone back at Thalmic
is super excited about.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
Let's rewind the clock.
How long have you been around,
and what was day one like?
What was day one when you
tried to develop this armband?
What were the struggles
that you got into?
Let's talk about the early
days of your project.
AARON GRANT: Yes.
So Thalmic Labs has been around
for about two years now--
just over two years.
It was founded by myself
and two other graduates
from the University of Waterloo.
And we basically got
together and decided
that we wanted to build
a company-- do something
together.
And so started looking
around for some things
we could work on.
And we were actually
thinking about this kind
of new wave of wearable
technology, a new form
factors of devices.
And what the best way to
control those and interact
with those devices
would be going forward.
And that's where the idea
for the Myo was born.
There are some camera-based
gesture control solutions
out there.
And there is, as you
can probably imagine,
a lot of limitations with having
to be in front of the camera
all the time.
And so we thought about how
we could overcome those.
And from that the Myo was born.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
So let's talk
about-- you developed
and designed the product.
What were you thinking about
in terms of getting out there?
Obviously, it's
something different.
People aren't used to it.
What did you do differently than
most other apps or start-ups
that are out there to
get your technology
in the hands of users?
AARON GRANT: Yeah.
So one of our biggest
challenges was
that if I walked up to
someone on the street
and told them that the Myo
was a gesture control armband,
they'd have no idea
what I'm talking about.
And it's a brand new technology.
It's not a new version
of something else
that already exists.
And so communicating to
people what the technology is,
why you would want to use
it, what it's good for,
is a difficult challenge.
And we knew that going into it.
So in terms of
getting it out there,
we thought of all sorts
of different things.
Like Kickstarter was an
obvious potential avenue
that we didn't exactly end
up going down that route.
But we really felt
that it would come down
to how well we could
explain what the product is,
what it can do, and why you
would actually want to use it.
MALE SPEAKER: Of course.
I think so many startups
struggle with that.
They have an amazing product.
And then when they try
to get to explaining it,
they do so many things.
Let's distill it to
a 10-second pitch.
Let's put together a
PowerPoint presentation.
But I want to talk
about something
that you did that just
really, really amazed me.
You guys put together this video
that I checked this morning.
You guys have over
three million hits.
There's no cats in this video.
It's like a viral video.
And it's about a product.
You guys do such an amazing
job of conveying that.
And it was still
in your early days
when you were still in the
product development phases.
So Aaron, talk to me about
how the team at Thalmic
thought about putting that video
together, especially when it's
so ahead of the product
development curve.
I thought that was a really
ingenious move on your part.
AARON GRANT: Yeah.
So backing up a
little before the time
when we actually created
that video, when we were just
trying to get the
company off the ground--
No matter who you're
talking to, whether it's
a potential investor,
or a potential employee,
or anyone else, you're
always pitching your idea.
And you're trying to
sell people on your idea
whether you're physically
selling them a product or not.
And we found that we had
a lot of trouble getting
the idea of the Myo
across just with words
and maybe a few of PowerPoint
slides or diagrams.
People would get it,
but it it didn't really
click just with that verbal
explanation of the technology.
And so we realized we needed
something more than that,
especially for when we wanted
to go and try and sell this
to millions of people.
And so we came up with the
idea of putting together
this essentially
concept video that
showcased a bunch of the
very different applications
that Myo could be used with.
And we felt that
would be a great way
to actually get across
what the product is,
what you can use it
for, and why there's
nothing else that
can really accomplish
what the Myo can do right now.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
So let's go through
this thought process.
So you decided a
video is the best
way to communicate our message.
And then you said, I'm
going to pull out my phone,
I'm going to record some
buddies in the office.
Working with Myo, you went
after a more professional agent.
I think so few
entrepreneurs even
think about making a
YouTube video related
to the product in their
early days, but you did.
Can you get us into the
nitty gritty of how exactly
you did that so perhaps
anybody in the audience
could replicate it if they're
trying to develop something
on their own?
AARON GRANT: Yeah, for sure.
So we thought about a few
different possibilities,
different ways of
doing it, storyboarded
out a few different things.
And one of the
main decisions was
whether to shoot
something ourself
and make it obviously a
home video kind of thing
and show some of
the early prototypes
and show what a lot
of Kickstarter videos
tend to do showing the
development process
and where we had come from
and where we're at today.
And that was one option
or make a really polished,
high production value video
showcasing at its best, what
Myo could be, and
really make a video that
would have a big
impact on people.
And we decided to
go the second route,
work with a local up and
coming up video production
company to go and produce
something just very visually
stunning, very high energy, high
impact video that would just
grab people's attention
and make them say, wow,
this is an awesome product.
And start to think of all
of the potential things
that they could do
with it as well.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
It sounds like you put the
entire city of Waterloo
to work.
I'm waiting for the
day where we're all
going to be like,
welcome to Waterloo,
home of Aaron Grant and
Thalmic Technologies.
So I think that's awesome.
So talk to me, also,
some of the stats
when we were catching up the
other day just really, really
amazed me.
You guys now have
40,000 pre-orders.
AARON GRANT: Yes, we do.
MALE SPEAKER: Is that right?
AARON GRANT: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And you guys
recently redesigned the armband
and put it out there.
So how many days has
it been since you
announced the redesign
and the launch?
AARON GRANT: So we announced
the basically final design
of the consumer
hardware that we'll
be shipping to all of
our pre-order customers
later this year.
And that was about
two weeks ago.
And the reception for that
has been absolutely fantastic.
And we couldn't be more
thrilled because we
spent six months redesigning,
essentially from scratch,
the entire Myo armbands
to make it something
that we're really
proud of and that we
think our users will love.
MALE SPEAKER: And
it's beautiful.
If you see that the
armband, you wouldn't
tell if it's a basketball-like
armband, sweatband.
It looks so seamless.
You guys did such a good job
of cutting it down and making
it look slim and sleek.
So these 40,000 pre-orders
have come in the past two weeks
alone.
AARON GRANT: So
these are pre-orders,
all of our pre-orders from
when we launched that video.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
And so talk to me
about how do you
generate so many pre-orders
for this product?
And give us the
price point again?
AARON GRANT: So it's
$149 for a pre-order.
MALE SPEAKER: $149
for a pre-order.
And you didn't spend a
dollar in paid marketing.
AARON GRANT: That's correct.
MALE SPEAKER: So how
else beyond the video
did you distribute
this technology?
How did you get the word out?
AARON GRANT: Yeah, so the
video was really the key.
And then, once we had that
and we were happy with it
and we tested it on
some people, made sure
that it got the idea across and
did what we wanted it to do,
we reached out to just a
handful of different reporters
and journalists, less
than five, and got
them to agree to write
a story about it.
And from there, it
essentially just took off.
We put a lot of time and
effort into making sure
that the video communicated
what we wanted it to
and how we wanted it to.
And from there, we just
gave it a little nudge,
and then it went from there.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
So talk to me also about
the developer community.
It sounds like you
have a lot of people
working on the Myo armband to
start developing your products,
apps so people can engage
in many different use cases
and make it their own.
How have you empowered
the developer community
with the Myo armband?
AARON GRANT: Yes, so
right from the beginning,
we've had a very, very
strong focus on developers.
And our goal with the Myo
is to essentially make
it a platform for
controlling and interacting
with your software
and hardware devices.
And so we have SDKs available
for all the major platforms--
Windows, Mac, iOS, Android.
We have a very active
developer community.
And actually, last
December, we began
shipping what we call our
alpha units to early developers
and partners to
get them starting
to work on
applications and learn
how they can use the technology.
And we're really
excited to be starting
to get the final consumer
hardware into the hands
of a much bigger developer
community starting next month.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
So Aaron, let's talk more
about the early days,
and were there any mistakes you
made when you look back like,
I wish we didn't distribute
the product this way.
Maybe in hindsight we
should have done something
differently.
Anything you would
have changed in terms
of getting the Myo
technology out there?
AARON GRANT: Everyone
makes mistakes, for sure.
Just because we had a fairly
successful pre-order campaign
doesn't mean that we
did everything right.
This is our first
time doing this.
We learned a lot along the way.
I think, looking back, the
route that we went down
in terms of producing the video
and selling these pre-orders
through our own
website, I still believe
that was the right decision.
There are obviously
little things
we could have done differently.
Maybe the timing wasn't perfect.
Some would say we should have
waited a bit longer to do this
so that our pre-order
customers wouldn't
be waiting for so long.
But as you say,
hindsight is 20/20.
MALE SPEAKER: And
so were you thinking
about developing on other
sites or doing other ecommerce
storefronts to take
the pre-orders?
And what ultimately
led you guys to want
to just post it yourselves?
AARON GRANT: So
we're big believers
in controlling the whole
product experience.
And that starts when
you watch the video
or go to the site
for the first time
and basically the first time you
hear about or see the product.
And so, the only way
that we could really
do that and make sure that
people have the experience we
want them to is to build
that all ourselves.
So that was a natural
way for us to go.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's
throw aside any cliches.
Let's not talk
about oh, the work
it takes to
distribute a product.
Obviously, you put a
lot of heart and sweat
in putting Myo out there.
What would you say to an
entrepreneur developer
today that's just trying to
get their product out there?
What advice, what
little nugget of insight
can you give them
that maybe you didn't
realize when you're
starting out?
AARON GRANT: Yeah, I think
this applies to more than just
distributing the
product, as well.
But when you're
just starting out
and you have very
few people, you
have way more things to
do than you have time.
You really, really have to
focus 100% on finding ways
to be resourceful
and get things done
that maybe seemed kind
of impossible at first.
Or figure out how to open doors
that seemed like maybe they're
a bit out of reach for now.
It comes down to
a lot of things.
One of them is
being very creative.
One of them is just
being gutsy enough
to go out and talk to people who
maybe you would think would not
want to talk to you at this
point, but you just try
and see what happens.
There's no harm in doing that.
And, yeah, just being very
creative and resourceful
in trying to find
ways, new, better
ways to do things that either
save time or save money or both
is really what's going to make
or break you in the early days.
MALE SPEAKER: And I guess
to bring this full circle,
talking about being resourceful
and saving money, how much did
that video that had over
3 million hits, what
was a ballpark figure of
how much that video cost?
AARON GRANT: So I can't disclose
the actual amount there.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
yeah, of course.
AARON GRANT: One
thing we did there
was we found a local up
and coming video production
company who the
publicity generated
would be equally valuable
for them as it would for us.
And by doing that,
we were able to avoid
some of the sky high
prices that would usually
be associated with producing
something like this.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Yeah, and if you
look at the video,
it's just so
professionally made.
It's worth every ounce
of those 3 million views.
And again, I encourage
you guys to check it out.
Just blows you away.
Sounds like it
inspired a lot of users
as well as your
team to just move
towards the vision
of your product.
So it's amazing how
you got that out there.
I just wanted to leave the
last few seconds here to you
in case there's
anything else you
want to talk about in
terms of the Myo technology
and getting it out
there before we open up
to the audience
for you guys to ask
any questions you
may have to Aaron.
So any final closing
words about the
struggles you had or just advice
to developers and entrepreneurs
in the audience today?
AARON GRANT: Yeah, I'll
just reiterate what I just
said about being resourceful.
You can't say that enough.
It's absolutely the key thing.
I'll give a little
anecdote for something
we did in our early days.
So one thing that's
traditionally
a lot more difficult with
hardware than software
is actually iterating
and making changes
and seeing those results
in a short amount of time.
Because you have to
actually build the thing.
And so something that we
did when we were still
funding the company on
our personal credit cards
was we scoured all the
local buy and sell websites
like Craigslist and
everything there,
and we found a guy
selling a 3D printer.
He had it in his basement.
It was a big industrial
grade 3D printer
that would cost around
$30,000, and we got it
for about an eighth of
the price from him there.
And using that, we were able
to make new prototypes in a day
rather than waiting two
weeks to get them back.
And so it enabled us to
iterate on the design much,
much, much faster, almost as
fast as we do with software.
And so, doing
things like that is
what really makes a difference.
MALE SPEAKER: Craigslist
saving the day again, I see.
Awesome, awesome.
So with that, we're
going to open up
to you guys for questions.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I was wondering what
Distribute 2.0 looks like, now
that you really hit it big
with word of mouth marketing.
What's your plan to spend
your first actual dollar
or is this the plan for now?
AARON GRANT: Yeah,
so right now, we're
focused on fulfilling the orders
to the pre-order customers
that we have right now.
And we'll be starting
to do that next month.
And once we've
shipped all those,
we'll be moving out into
retail, and with that, the wider
availability of the Myo,
we'll have more marketing
and everything around there.
I can't really talk
about exactly what that
will look like at
this time, but you
can expect that later this year.
MALE SPEAKER: In the back.
AUDIENCE 2 : Just
had two questions.
So the first was when you
look for team members, what
did you look for in
putting a team together?
I think that's
probably the hardest
part of a start-up
in any company.
And then the second
is, how did you
come up with the idea
for the Myo band?
AARON GRANT: OK, so to
answer the first question.
The founding team, myself
and the two other founders,
we had been classmates
for five years.
And I think that was, aside
from being resourceful,
probably the second
key thing that
has helped us get to
where we are today
because we had that
initial core team.
We had had experience
working together,
we had pulled all
nighters together,
we had gone on trips
together, lived together.
And more so than
anything else, we
knew that we could trust each
other, no matter what happened.
And that's really,
really, really important.
Especially when it's
just the three of you.
And especially when you have
to make a decision when,
say, two of the other founders
are traveling around the world
and something comes up, you
have to decide immediately,
we can trust that they're going
to make the correct decision.
And I think we were fortunate in
that sense that the three of us
already knew each other and
we were in that position.
We already had the team.
That's what I would
look for if you're
building a team from scratch is,
don't just go and find someone
on the street that you just met.
You definitely want people
that you know you can trust,
you have some sort
of past history with.
Ideally you've done projects
or worked together before
or something like that.
Sorry.
What was the second question?
AUDIENCE 2: How did you come
up with the idea for the Myo?
AARON GRANT: Right.
Yes.
So we came up with the
idea, we were thinking
about these new form
factors of computing
and where wearable
tech is going,
where the smartphone's going
to be five years from now.
And we realized that
there's another opportunity
for the way we interact
with and control devices.
And so people use their
hands to naturally
interact with things already.
People are very familiar with
gesturing with their hands
and controlling things.
Even if it's just picking
something up and putting it
down or opening a door.
You control things and interact
with things with your hands
already.
And so, we wanted to find a
way that you could do that
without having to use
a vision-based method.
And so that's where
the idea came from was,
how can we control things
naturally with our hands
without being in front
of a camera all the time.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
Well, if there's
no other questions,
I just want to say
thank you to Aaron
for joining us here at I/O
and I really [INAUDIBLE].
AARON GRANT: Oh, thank you.
It's been great.
I appreciate it.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Great.